hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so for those who are watching my video
for the first time let me quickly
introduce myself
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years
in hong kong and right now i'm doing
youtube videos
to show you guys everything that i
learned at work mostly myself i read of
course many books
but i didn't have a teacher and i think
that it's the best way to
learn fast so that's why i'm doing this
video i try to
explain as good as i can everything that
i use at work
all the different tools and techniques
that work for me and so that you guys
can do it yourself so i'm here to pass
the
knowledge and today i want to show you
some very interesting things
on football tv let's get into it
[Music]
and guys i like to follow the stock
because you know it's for me
a very interesting stock i know there
was a lot of bullish momentum
in this whole way up and have some
friends even some family
that along the stock and they are asking
me to make some updates
so i did and right now guys i feel like
i'm involved in this
stock so i'm gonna keep updating you
with the price action that is coming
so let me remind you first quickly
what we're having here so i keep my
drawings guys this drawing i did it
but i did it on the 18th of airport so
more than one month ago
and you can see that we broke 20 so i
told you careful we're gonna probably go
to 15 which we did guys
so i was here correct then i told you
that we
are waiting for the breakout of this
trend line and that we're gonna have
those strong moves up and look guys this
is the drawing i did
more than one month ago so i'm very much
into what is happening and i told you
guys that when the breakout here
happens it's the time to enter so
you can use the daily time frame or the
four hours time frame
but on both time frames you have the
breakout here
confirmed so on this day on the 25th of
may it was confirmed
so if you buy when it's confirmed which
is the theory of
the breakout training technique then you
are
already in the in this trade if you
haven't bought here you might have maybe
one more chance
we can maybe retest one more time but to
be honest i think we're just gonna go
higher from here so let's see even
buying here is
not a bad idea for me you know we're
having this
trend line as well here you can see on
the shorter term it's a consolidation
consolidation area and we are above so
maybe we're going to retest 22.5 you
know
but basically i would already be in the
stream if i'm not
i would maybe buy some shares because i
believe we're gonna go much higher
but i don't like to buy high if i if i
missed this opportunity that was here i
would maybe
wait for a test or maybe by half here
and another half here
but whatever here we are bullish and
everything
looks good the macd is positive we went
to those very low levels to get the
liquidity that sometimes the market
needs guys all right that the market
needs to you know you need to have
everyone on your side
to win a battle so you need to go for
every buyers if they are at lower levels
you need to go to
this levels take back the liquidity
they're going to bring you
because if the more buyers they are
involved in the price action
the easier it's going to be to actually
beat the
sellers so here you can see as well that
if you connect this trend line
this low is this low here we almost have
this one and this would have helped us
as well to get the 15 level just a small
thing i want you to tell you
even if it's too late but i gave you
this level before it happened
so here what are we expecting we're
expecting as usual a bullish development
in five waves guys so we do the counting
we go on the hourly time frame
and let's do some counting together i
haven't done it so
sorry i keep this drawing here but i
think it's interesting
and let's see what we're having so this
is a one
this is a two all right so this is
a three that is one two three so this is
we're gonna have something like this
probably guys
okay and this would be only a first wave
so what i'm expecting
is something like this right now okay
okay guys this is probably what is gonna
play out
all right so of course i'm gonna update
you more
with the levels if this is the third
wave he's gonna probably
take back those levels so maybe
something like this
but it's gonna be impulsive guys it's
gonna be impulsive
so of course this is for now
approximative i'm gonna give you
uh more precise timings and
levels when i'm gonna see clearer for
now what i see is that we're still in
this
five wave development here that is not
complete so that's why i think
we're gonna keep going higher once again
we might as well be like this
we cannot correct here otherwise it
would be yeah
it could be still a leading diagonal but
usually first waves you know down five
waves and are impulsive
that the force wave doesn't enter wave
one territory but
still there is a pattern that is called
the leading diagonal so it means that
it can happen a diagonal is something
weaker
that is in five waves too but the force
wave enters wave one territory
that's why here if i see the false wave
coming
here this would be a leading diagonal
which is possible yes but most likely
we won't have this we would first do the
five ways then correct
and then go higher so once again
i think there's going to be for sure
once this five waves development is
going to be complete
there's going to be a correction so you
can still enter this trade here around
mid-june end of june we're probably
gonna have a dip
here where we're gonna be able to buy
some shares
at a good level and here you can use
let's see where the
fifth wave is going probably gonna go
around the 30 area
so let's say we go to 30 then usually
what i like to do to buy the 50 and the
61.8
so around 22 20. so if you see 22
20 right now it's a good level to buy
because it's probably gonna be the same
level we're going to buy
in end of june so let's better even
doing it right now if the opportunity
occurs to sum up bullish we have this
breakout confirmation here so right now
we are gonna develop higher you know
like
with a very much increased probability
i would say 80 90 chance that we keep
going higher we correct and then we go
around the 60 90 area so
not sure when i would say september you
know something like this but
this you know i think before the end of
the summer
so this is my view let's see how this
plays out and i'm going to keep updating
you guys on the stock that i like
and that's it for me so hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
bell button so you're gonna be the first
to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i'll see you
guys